algún día un palíndromo les puede salvar
la vida
en estos tiempos donde abundan los
métodos las técnicas y las terapias para
mejorar la salud y el rendimiento es
extraño que nadie haya reparado aún en
las virtudes de los palíndromos yo les
voy a hablar de eso
habré tenido unos 78 años cuando mi
abuela me presento a los palíndromos me
dijo que escriba el nombre de esta
hermosa provincia argentina y luego me
dictó esta famosa frase me dijo que la
lea al revés daba le arroz a la zorra el
haba no lo podía creer estaba
maravillado no sabía qué significaba un
abad ni tenía otra interpretación para
la palabra zorra pero sabía que ahí
había magia
y esa mágica era la magia de una pasión
que se estaba despertando en mí desde
estos tiempos empecé a leer todas las
palabras hacia atrás y me di cuenta que
estamos rodeados de palíndromos
invisibles hasta ese momento ante mis
ojos
luego empecé a buscar los palíndromos
más ingeniosos que había creados con
frases tan hermosas como amo la pacífica
paloma nos ideó edison
yo hago yoga hoy
o la ruta nos aportó otro paso natural
acceso es tiempo para mí crear
palíndromo ser algo de escaños absolutos
como los físicos desde recién o alguna
revelación mística de ese modo yo
explicaba palíndromos tan perfectos como
heba y llave o simplemente a la después
me di cuenta que crear palíndromos lo
puede hacer cualquiera y sólo descubrí
en un ascensor leyendo el botón de la
luz y descubrí el poético luz azul del
mismo modo siendo un baño de un bar
descubrí él soñaba baños desde esos
desde ese tiempo empecé a crear mis
propios palíndromos empecé con frases
como ánimo de mono me domina
luego con pequeños poemas poemas más
complejos historietas ilustradas y va
probando formas hasta que llegue a
escribir un palíndromo super extenso y
complejo que era la obsesión que había
tenido desde siempre que tiene seis mil
886 palabras y que abarca 70 páginas más
o menos en total y fueron cuatro meses
de completa locura que al final termine
sofocado con un libro completamente
inútil y nada popular
pero era lo que yo buscaba
y yo creo que es aquí donde está el
límite entre la pasión y la locura
porque esto que para la psiquiatría
puede ser un síntoma de una neurosis o
para la economía la inversión de tiempo
útil en algo completamente improductivo
para mí significó
el conseguir una meta que yo estaba
buscando si yo creo que sea cual sea esa
meta por más ridícula o absurda que sea
es donde se define el límite entre la
verdadera pasión y la simple locura
y por cierto los palíndromos son una
actividad muy saludable por eso ahora yo
les voy a contar de todos sus beneficios
y les voy a decir por qué algún día un
palíndromo les puede salvar la vida
pero antes vamos a empezar con un veloz
recorrido histórico por la palindromía
para darles una idea uno de los primeros
antecedentes que se tiene es el cuadrado
mágico en algunas ruinas romanas de
europa que además de ser bidireccional
tiene otra dirección vertical esto le ha
dado el nombre de cuadrado mágico que
además serán hecho interpretaciones
numerológicas cabalísticas y hasta
religiosas vinculados siempre a la más
que los palíndromos luego a lo largo de
los siglos encontramos algunos
palíndromos dispersos como este latino
inscripto en una ruina en unas iglesias
de europa este griego también inscripto
en iglesias de europa 1 latino atribuido
a dante alighieri 1 en italiano a miguel
ángel y así llegamos al siglo 20 donde
la palindromía empieza a florecer
primero de la mano de escritores
consagrados como james joyce en la en
habla inglesa y en nuestro idioma
nuestro compatriota juan filloy uno de
los primeros coleccionistas y teóricos
de la palindromía
el mexicano a gusto monterroso en un
capítulo llamado ovnis es asesino de uno
de sus libros nuestro querido julio
cortázar en un cuento lejana nombre 4
palíndromos que ya él los hizo famoso y
el venezolano darío lanzini que en su
libro ir a darío empieza con los
primeros poemas y producciones
literarias palin dromi cash y así
llegamos a finales del siglo 20 con el
club palindromista internacional donde
un grupo de intelectuales lúdicos y un
poco excéntricos se juntan a compartir
palíndromos y editar una revista desde
el año 87 hasta la mix in hasta la misma
fecha de hoy
dedicada a los palíndromos como se
imaginarán cuando conocí este grupo para
mí fue una felicidad tremenda por
primera vez conocí a alguien que podía
compartir esta pasión excéntrica conmigo
y fue una prueba de que tan loco no
estaba
y ahora empieza al decir de mi amigo
pero ruiz la era de oro de los
palíndromos porque hay a pensar que la
gente ni conozca la palabra miles de
palíndromos en el mundo de todos tamaños
de todas formas palindromista en todos
los países y se ha iniciado una ola de
publicaciones palin dromi cash con el
objetivo de jerarquizar este arte y con
ese objetivo en 2009 iniciamos el grupo
el movimiento libre literario palin
dromi co rever que el objetivo es hacer
que el palíndromo de ser un simple juego
y se lo considere una forma literaria
una verdadera composición literaria
y de ese modo en la palindromía llega
hoy aquí en 2003 7 de c's y yo me
propongo demostrarles que además de un
juego y una composición literaria tiene
que ser considerado un método de
entrenamiento mental
por eso les voy a contar 10 de sus
beneficios para nuestra salud mental y
finalmente les voy a decir por qué un
palíndromo algún día les puede salvar la
vida
la experiencia palindromía es su
experiencia muy particular una mezcla
entre ser cruz jamás y escribir poesías
un juego y una búsqueda de sentido
además el palíndromo es una obra activa
porque está implicada en su propia
creación mientras uno escribe un lado el
palíndromo se auto escribe del otro esto
da particularidades muy interesantes y
beneficios a nuestra salud intelectual
por ejemplo ejercita holísticamente el
cerebro este es el primero de los
beneficios una vez en una presentación
una maestra me dijo que le interesaba en
los palíndromos porque trabajaba con
personas con alzheimer como todo juego
de ingenio ejercita la lógica del
cerebro pero el palíndromo va más allá
porque la simetría ejercita la
intelectualidad del hemisferio izquierdo
pero la búsqueda de sentido la intuición
del hemisferio derecho por eso es una
explicación holística en un mismo
ejercicio estimula la sorpresa y la
creatividad nunca sabemos cómo va a
terminar un palíndromo y eso nos conecta
con la creatividad que todos tenemos
dentro
nos conecta con el juego y la risa
porque es un juego que lo hacemos
seriamente y entendemos que siempre
podemos darle un sentido lúdico a la
vida y siempre nos regale una sonrisa
por más que no sea gracioso
nos revela la importancia de lo
insignificante porque cada letra en un
palíndromo fundamental y ahí entendemos
el valor de las pequeñas cosas
promueve el cambio de enfoque porque
empezamos a escribir un palíndromo y del
otro lado nos aparece algo completamente
distinto si escribimos amor aparece romá
entonces de un enfoque amoroso pasamos a
un histórico y así inevitablemente
tenemos que estar cambiando enfoque y
buscando soluciones alternativas nos
despierta habilidades dormidas nos exige
un pensamiento tan complejo a veces que
despierta habilidades que ni siquiera
nosotros sabíamos que realmente teníamos
nos induce a la búsqueda del equilibrio
porque el pali no básicamente es
equilibrar el sentido de los dos
extremos y esto inmediatamente lo
llevamos a la vida
no es amiga con el fracaso porque recién
palíndromos que empezamos uno
probablemente llegue a un fin
satisfactorio en este sentido el fracaso
de crecer un fantasma y empieza a ser un
tramo inevitable en el camino al éxito
ejercita la flexibilidad y la adaptación
en la búsqueda de objetivos porque nos
enseña cuando tenemos que acatar las
circunstancias de las leyes que son muy
rígidas y cuándo atacar para llegar
inevitablemente al palíndromos porque
sin esa convicción terminamos diciendo
es imposible hacer palíndromos y que no
lo es y finalmente nos ofrece respuestas
a dudas existenciales porque como dije
el palíndromo siempre nos sorprende y
está vinculado a un a un aire de magia
en este sentido lo podemos usar como un
oráculo para preguntar sobre dudas
existenciales de nuestras vidas
por ejemplo cuando mi amigo cristian
dijo si podía venir acá como era un poco
complicado acudir a la palin drom ansia
y encontré acude y educa
entonces tuvo que
inevitablemente tuve que responder yo
voy pero del mismo modo y qué es lo que
nos trae acá para ir concluyendo podemos
apelar para preguntar sobre el sentido
de la vida y la pregunta por el sentido
es siempre una pregunta por el ser en
este camino a la búsqueda de la propia
ocasión que está lleno de dudas y de
obstáculos podemos ser lo que se nos
impone personas adaptadas normales
productivas o ser lo que realmente somos
en este punto el palíndromo es
inflexible y las respuestas son
contundentes se es o no se es
somos o no somos y por si les queda
alguna duda insiste sos o nosotros
así podemos ver que los palíndromos nos
enseñan que no hay escapatoria
debemos asumir lo que somos enfrentar
nuestra pasión por más absurda o
extravagante que pueda llegar a ser y
con convicción pararnos frente al mundo
y decir yo soy sobre lo que busco soy lo
que elijo soy lo que quiero simplemente
yo soy
para finalizar les tengo que decir no me
olvidado porque algún día un palíndromo
les puede salvar la vida imagínense si
se pierden en un desierto inexplorado o
en alguna isla desierta un palíndromo
les puede salvar la vida